so good afternoon everybody and welcome
back we had an awesome morning session
and now we're gonna have an awesome er
or some my English is failing me session
and you're gonna kick things off with an
outstanding speech from a great friend
of Metro 21 Dave Roger so you know metal
21 wouldn't have happened if not for the
vision and support of Henry Hillman and
the Hillman foundation and Dave Roger
has been a critical critical component
of working side by side with us
supporting many projects and actually
being one of the folks that have also
provided us with guidance and input on
some of the things that you've heard us
speak about earlier this morning I could
go on and on about Dave I'm going to
keep this very brief and give him the
opportunity to address us so Dave thanks
again from Jim myself Raj Karen and Rick
thanks so much for that
okay thank you everyone
now for the awesomeness are you ready so
I was asked to say a few words today
about about how we got here and I'm
gonna try not to give you the long
boring history but but a few highlights
that I think are relevant to where we go
from here and what and why we want to
talk about these things so the the seeds
for for Metro 21 were planted on the
afternoon of Tuesday February 17 2009
and you may wonder why do I know that
date in time so well because this is
what prompted her right here this was a
section from The Wall Street Journal and
it says February 17 2009 that's one over
date and I know it was 10 o'clock
because around 10 o'clock in the morning
was when Henry would arrive at the
office and he called and Henry had a
deep voice if you knew him and he would
say Dave do you have a few minutes to
come over so I go over to Henry's office
and he's got this sitting in front of
him and he
you know I've been thinking a lot about
all of these assets we have in
Pittsburgh and we have these amazing
universities and a lot of smart people
and we have these interesting urban
problems right mainly around
infrastructure specifically the
intersection of more wooden Forbes which
he drove through every day on his way to
and from the office and he always hated
sitting at that traffic light when there
was no one else around
so soon that the conversation turned to
that traffic light and he said I
wondered if this technology could help
me get home faster because Henry's life
consisted of thinking and strategizing
and the more time he could spend
thinking and strategizing the happier
was and when he was sitting in traffic
he wasn't doing that so in looking at
this article it was it had been an
interest of ours so we've been noodling
around with this idea for a while but
what what synthesized it for us in that
moment was Henry's thought that look we
have these amazing assets but we're not
utilizing them to deploy this technology
in Pittsburgh we should be a world
leader we should be the place or anyone
around the world who wants to see this
on the ground wants to go you've got to
go to Pittsburgh if you want to see how
they're using smart infrastructure so
that's really how it started and the
next thing that happened again I'm gonna
spare you the history because Ric has
done a wonderful job writing in a case
study so you should read the case study
and it'll be accurate and Ric is a
stickler for accuracy on these things as
I known as as so so I'm gonna spare you
the the long story but it led to a
conversation with Jerry Cohen who was
the president of the University at that
time and over the course of a glass of
wine with Jerry one evening we we posed
this idea is there is there possibility
for an initiative that could pull these
assets together and the reason we call
Jerry was in doing our own background
research we realized that CMU had
everything that you needed to launch
this you had you had policy which we we
actually started with policy we didn't
start with the technology but when you
unpack the technology you were working
on automated vehicle so you had people
like Ross who had been at this for 20
years already you were in artificial
intelligence you had a strong
engineering department and you had this
cross departmental interdisciplinary way
of doing things and you
make stuff and you teach people how to
make stuff so I'm not gonna single you
out Steve don't worry
yeah so uh by combining these assets we
thought this is really a way to
distinguish this city this University
and a community of people who can come
together to solve real-world problems so
uh it wasn't very long that the jerod
encouraged me to come to the campus and
start meeting some of the the research
faculty who would ultimately work on
this that's when I met Jim Garrett it
was before he became Dean and there this
room is filled with people whom I should
name that I met on that day but at the
time Rick McCullough was the VP of
research and Rick could walk me around
the campus made all the introductions
and on the way out Rick said you know
I'm convinced we have something here he
said do you think you could put a little
seed money into into this project which
we agreed to do it became clear that
this was gonna spiral into something a
lot larger we had a conversation
internally about how do we we make this
work I couldn't manage it I was already
spending a good bit of time on it Henry
and I had a conversation with type of
person we would want to manage this
there was really one person we had in
mind he happened to be here at the
university already Brooks Stafford I'm
gonna humiliate Rick because he hates to
be he hates to be praised in any way but
it really Rick was the person who put
the the core thinking together behind
the strategy and how we could launch
something that was really just an
initiative and eventually became a
center and then a federally funded
center and now something much much more
comprehensive I do have to give Rick
McCullough credit though on that very
day that we were meeting the research
faculty Rick said you know I have this
vision that this can be bigger than
transportation this can be a much much
larger more comprehensive effort we
should be looking at city data and using
city data to solve lots of problems
beyond transportation we can apply this
to stormwater other areas of
infrastructure we can apply this to the
way we deliver human services he had a
big big picture in mind and I remember
saying specifically to Rick Henry just
wants to fix the signal it Forbes and
Moore would love to take on all these
other issues but let's get started and
we'll see where it goes
so it's it's just a way of saying when
you start something you don't quite know
where it's going to go and you have to
be open to to where
where it's gonna go but back to back to
the the point this was about Henry and
in the vision for I was supposed to be
about Henry in the vision that he had
for this so you need to know a few
things about him okay I mentioned he
loved to strategize right loved a
project anytime there was a way to solve
something and you make a project out of
it he was never afraid to grab that and
try to do it didn't matter if we had the
domain expertise or not we could find it
we'd figured out but but grab projects
strategize fix things if you can he
never looked back
so when I started working for the
foundation he was already 80 years old
in my mind he seemed like he was 60 he
was a much C much younger at 80 years
old he had lived through World War two
he was an aviator in the Navy in World
War two he would never talk about it
he wouldn't say word about it it was no
no that's in the past what are we gonna
do next week you know what's gonna
happen next month what's the strategy
for the foundation the long-term future
and if you've read anything about us he
was extraordinarily generous when he
passed away last year and left a very
large estate gift to the foundations to
carry this work on and traffic 21 was
really the test model for us it showed
us that we can take on large initiatives
we can help solve big problems we can
assemble talent we can put a consortium
together we can work with government we
can work with industry in ways that we
hadn't before so in many ways what we're
going to be doing with the Foundation's
going forward was shaped by this
experience with traffic 21 I have a
little bit more of it to Rick for that
but this was our chance to figure out
how we could play a bigger role in
Pittsburgh and in the world by
reorienting what we do every day and it
you know 80 years old Henry was already
open to that idea so another lesson from
Henry is don't get locked into things so
you should have a plan you should stay
on the plan you should try to execute on
it but you have to be able to iterate
and when the time comes to change you
have to be ready to change and move on
to the next thing and I think that's a
lesson that we've learned with with
traffic 21 start traffic 21 it's a small
initiative looks like a center there's
this opportunity to become a university
transportation center USDOT said no
chance it happened within a year I think
was about a year the tea set is formed
be pretty soon the larger vision of
forming metro 21 starts to grow and that
happens so it's iterate iterate iterate
iterate follow the
opportunity and I think we see the
impact of it now how many supported
University Research Projects how many
community partnerships so I'll stop
there the the last thing I want to talk
a little bit about is the partnership
with the city in the county which which
is unique to this vision that Henry had
that we can be a testbed for deployment
we've got great partners in the city in
the county and in PennDOT too we
couldn't have done this if they weren't
willing partners and all of it yeah
there's a i'll give you up this is the
joke part of the of the lunch speech so
picture a 1950's gameshow and in one
side of the room you have elected
officials and in the other side of the
room you have university researchers and
they're in these sequestered chambers
and it's a quiz show and the the
question that's about to be asked is a
math problem and if you answer one
problem correctly you go on if you don't
you stop so the the first problem the
host says again the two sides can't hear
each other he says the problem is what
is the sum of five plus five bang the
university research chamber goes off
answer is ten correct then there's a
long awkward silence the clock's ticking
eventually the buzzer sounds and the
host says well elected officials do you
have an answer and the elected officials
say we think that the answer is
somewhere between nine and a half and
ten and a half which is correct right so
the point is that there are different
ways of looking at problems right you
come to it as a researcher with a
certain mindset look that officials look
at it a little bit differently they have
to but by combining the skill sets and
thinking through problems and working
together and kind of hammering it out
things happen we wouldn't have had a
signal pilot with with suretrack at the
intersection in front of the Target
store in East Liberty if it hadn't been
for the ability to work through these
issues the first answer was no the
second answer was well how would it work
and then it was no and then the third
answer was I think maybe no a third time
and then you work through it and
eventually things happen and you have a
pilot and it works and now you have a
company formed out of it so it's this
idea that you can keep iterating on
ideas you can't do it alone you have to
have this combination of these community
resources the university research
willing government partners some funding
support and a lot of corporate partners
along the way - that was Henry's vision
for this and I think we've more than
accomplished it so what I what I see
happening with Metro 21 is we have this
wonderful platform to keep building upon
hopefully it's going to grow there'll be
more opportunity and we're going to
expand in other areas that we're not
currently in right now I it so it's a
perfect moment to launch this so it's
great to have Karen here I there are a
million people in this room I should
thank for all of the hard work that
they've put into traffic 21 starting
with Raj and with with Ric Krishna and
Jim you guys were there from the very
beginning and helped us frame and shape
this but about Karen it's in good hands
right now
you know from here on with with Stan and
with Chris you've got this great team
together I can't imagine a better place
to launch forward from here finally just
want to thank Farnum for his support the
university has been a incredible partner
and Farnam has taken a particular
interest in Metro 21 so that's how we
got here I hope there are a few lessons
to be learned going forward and thank
you
[Applause]